some things haven't changed at the
gobblers aletta bang in rural bavaria
just like in olden times today's
accounts have to be balanced without
balance everything's worthless says
senior manager yo gobbler he keeps the
bank's illustrious history safely locked
away it is its first loan agreement 185
years ago the first loan went to a
farmer Dave I know you basically it was
still very straightforward half a page
in stood in 1828 and in 1828 the money
came back the money came back again and
again just a bit more than when out and
it was invested in only the barest
essentials that might swap filled me at
that time it was all about vital
necessities and if someone didn't have
the money for them they came to the bank
but nowadays they come and ask for money
to buy a house in Croatia I was in
Karachi and carved if all the veins in
the world were like the gobblers aletta
bank there might never have been a
financial crisis it's easy to hear how
money has lost weight over the years the
silver ling gives a resounding ring but
the Reichsmarks sounds thinner the first
deutsche mark the last item on our even
thinner and the euro hardly rings at all
money is only as valuable as the
people's faith in it following that old
truism help this Bank whether the worst
of the crisis another principle these
bangers stick to is never deal in
securities they don't understand and
they stand behind the risks they take
with their own money I put up my entire
fortune my father put up his entire
fortune and my colleague had why Nick
puts up his entire fortune in today's
bank's personal guarantees are all but
unthinkable and the managers are
generally employees not private owners
they play with other people's money
govno says only the state can rein in
their taste for whiskey deals
and yet the new regulations have hit the
smallest banks the hardest via mizzen
infinitely stones our igloo is a
relative to our size we have to invest
too much manpower time and effort into
complying with all the bureaucratic
requirements else for the Roman einheit
the bangers at gobblers aletta can't
continue their antiquated method of
business correspondence they have the
impression that one reason the
regulations are raining down is because
they no longer have to be tediously
written by hand the european union
sweeping legislation makes no
distinction between big banks and small
private ones how many chickens have you
got 15 and how many eggs do they lay 10
or 12 but daily dozen at quitting time
the bankers trade their business suits
for overalls they came from farming
backgrounds and farmers are their best
customers but even farmers are dealing
with more and more red tape the gobblers
make it their business to know the
farmers business it was the language of
the right the hidden all right we want
to keep agriculture up and running
because our banks family tradition and
its origins are rooted in agriculture
and are inseparably bound to it abundant
bangers in rubber boots regulators
should try it before they lend other
people's money they ought to know the
hard work it took to earn it